ciao a tutti quando avevo 17 anni ho
vissuto
identifico come la mia crisi mistica
perché perché non mi andava niente bene
di quello che stavo facendo e della vita
che stavo svolgendo a 17 anni io abitavo
in un paesino sperduto nelle montagne a
1300 metri in mezzo a boschi macugnaga e
io li ero mi sentivo un pesce fuor
d'acqua perché perché innanzitutto mi
sentivo ingabbiato non c'era niente da
fare tutti sti boschi o 17 anni volevo
divertirmi ai tempi frequentavo la
scuola alberghiera perché io vengo da
una famiglia di ristoratori dal mio
bisnonno e quindi ovviamente è andiamo a
fare la scuola alberghiera però non ero
convinto di quello che stavo facendo
e poi in quegli anni facevo il lo
sciatore facevo il le gare di sci però
cavolo è sempre ferito pattinare ma
perché dovevo tenere questi sci non
potevo mettere i miei pattini e poi coi
miei genitori
sapete benissimo che 17 anni il rapporto
coi nostri genitori non è proprio
fantastico i conflitti noi stiamo
creando la nostra identità vogliamo
farci vedere al mondo i nostri genitori
si tarpano le ali
il ricordo quando tornavo a casa con i
pantaloni quelli col cavallo basso
mia madre mi guardo quelli con le
ginocchia rotte mia madre mi guarda mi
dice matteo ma non abbiamo neanche piu
soldi per potergli pantaloni gioco
giusti e poi iniziamo ascoltare la io
ascoltavo lievi metal a 17 anni
heavy metal mi ricordo una volta metto
su un un primo album degli iron maiden
che lo ha acquistato dall epoca e mio
padre entra in camera ma tu stai
ascoltando musica satanica papa ma tu
ascolti pure io non posso ascoltare gli
iron maiden e metallica e così andava
avanti così andare avanti in quegli anni
lì mi sentivo quello che vedete qua in
questa in questa slide una una zattera
una zattera in balia dell'oceano rimane
in mare aperto
senza remi con delle onde enormi e non
riuscivo a vederla terraferma in quegli
anni ovviamente 17 anni io non sapevo
nulla di crescita personale autostima
atteggiamento motivazione niente mi ero
convinto che la mia vita dipendesse cioè
la mia felicità dipendesse completamente
dal mondo esterno cioè dai miei genitori
dalla mia scuola da tutto quello che mi
stava capitando
ricordo un giorno entrò nell'edicola e
di macugnaga voleva acquistare era una
delle cose che in quell'epoca mi dava
ancora mi appassionava mi piaceva
leggere il dylan dog il fumetto allora
entrò in edicola faccio per prendere il
dylan dog con la coda dell'occhio vede
una rivista che dice è un titolo tipo
impara a gestire i tuoi pensieri per
trasformare la tua vita un momento
aspetta però così tipo a un certo punto
perché volevo prendere tutte e due
allora ho preso sia dylan dog che la
rivista ho pagato sono uscito e mi sono
recato in un posto che in quegli anni
frequentavo che era una specie era un
pacchettino di una vecchia casa
abbandonata con questa bella panca in
sasso questo tavolo in sasso c'era
bellissimo perché c'era l'ombra dei
larici dei larici maestosi miss ed all
in appoggio al dylan dog e inizia a
sfogliare la rivista vado su
quell'articolo ho letto l'articolo che
diceva queste cose sul pensiero impara a
gestire il tuo pensiero trasformato a
vita ho letto tutta la rivista tutta non
avevo capito benissimo però sapete
quando iniziato a fare qualcosa che a un
certo punto ho sentite che vi risuona
dentro di te questa roba che mi piace e
non la conosco ancora ma mi piace ed è
morta lì la scuola non sono mai stato un
grande studioso non era un secchione
studia chiavo giusto per prendere voti
decenti perché il voto perché non voleva
storia dei miei genitori volevo cercare
comunque di leader e sereno allora
studia chiavo però ogni volta che io
arrivavo a scuola
il giorno che c'era la possibilità di
essere interrogati io andavo in ansia
eppure quando la sapete che sei giorno
dell'interrogazione la professoressa vi
guarda in sta a guardare la classe e
dice oggi interroghiamo io in quegli
anni errore mi ero cercavo di
specializzarmi nel mimetismo criptico in
un medesimo critico è quello che usano
certi animali per cercare di stanno
fermi e stando fermi non si fanno vedere
dall'occhio del predatore rari mi
fermava così sul banco tra un certo
punto nero bravissimo iniziamo andare
giù per cercare di nascondermi dietro al
banco e la professoressa inevitabilmente
perché comunque il movimento c'era viola
ha studiato e quel momento veramente
partiva a nico mi sudavano le mani
tachicardia immaginavo nel giro di un
secondo tutta la scena di me che in modo
bradipo mi avvicinavo dal banco per
andare dove li all'interrogazione arriva
vola con tutta questa bella confusione
mentale cosa faceva matteo però scena
muta volava dal posto allora mi sono
iniziato a fare delle domande ma perché
io nonostante la lezione la conosco è
che non riesco ad arrivare la maga una
slide fa niente perché quel quale motivo
mi sono interrogato e ho iniziato a
scoprire una cosa interessante è il
principio del pensiero cioè il pensiero
è una forza creativa che ognuno di noi
sa che al potere di creare la vita una
vita che potrebbe essere una vita da
sogno ma anche una vita che potrebbe
essere una vita disastrosa e il pensiero
parte immaginatevi matteo il giorno
prima della famosa interrogazione mi
parte il pensiero pensiero domani se
l'interrogazione con dio io non so
niente
oggi non so niente e quindi questo
pensiero è collegato delle immagini ed
erano le immagini di me che al banco
sudavo alla vita che cardia e facevo
scena muta
queste non le immagini a questa immagine
ad ogni immagine che voi avete nella
mente c'è collegata un'emozione sempre
fateci caso
e quale era l'emozione che io percepivo
secondo voi
con questo tipo di pensiero nella testa
era una un'emozione bella di motivazione
e stavo bene no provavo ansia provavo
paura e questa cosa tra l'altro più
continuo a pensare all esito nefasto
della mia interrogazione cresceva dentro
di me
tanto che arriva il giorno del
dell'interrogazione è io non dormivo la
notte e quindi qual era il comportamento
che metteva in atto tendenzialmente era
quello che vedo mi dicevo prima cioè
scena muta
ovviamente il risultato era pessimo
quel risultato li andava va sempre a
confermare il pensiero iniziale cioè
arriverò davanti alla professoressa fare
scena muta
quindi praticamente vi rendete conto che
è sempre un circolo vizioso
noi ce la scriviamo ce la cantiamo ce la
suoniamo cela plaudiamo facciamo tutto e
noi in quegli anni li ha o inizia c'è un
pochettino dopo ho iniziato a studiare
tutto quello che ad approfondire tutto
questo mondo del pensiero dell'autostima
e ho capito grazie a un grandissimo
corse che poi ho avuto modo di
frequentare di leggere i suoi libri che
si chiama michael miller o capito il
principio del pensiero di come funziona
il pensiero come vi dicevo prima questa
forza creativa enorme che possiamo
iniziare ad utilizzare perché avevo
provato a fare tutto a un certo punto e
ho provato con la meditazione prima van
detto tu quella meditazione impari
insegne al tuo cervello a non a non
pensare più a non è vero
ambientazione non serve per quello e poi
avevo provato il pensiero positivo del
testo va tanto di moda a pensare
positivo ti dicono penso sempre positivo
vedrai che poi le cose cambiano anche
questa cosa qui era abbastanza
insostenibile per me perché a un certo
punto non funzionava io come faccio
sempre a pensare positivo anche quando
c'è il disastro quando vedo che tarante
mezzo a un problema e poi ho capito
grazie a maicon il la natura del
pensiero il pensiero non è un problema
non è né bello né brutto è semplicemente
quello che noi facciamo con quel
pensiero
cioè se un pensiero arriva il pensiero
come una nuvola arriva entra nel nostro
campo visivo immaginate una giornata di
sole arriva il pensiero copre il sole e
voi a un certo punto cosa fate quando
diventa nuvolo potete lamentarvi o
preoccuparvi a un certo punto quella
nuvola come arrivata se ne va
esattamente come il pensiero seconda
comprendete la natura del pensiero che
va e viene
non state più lì a rimuginare lo quel
pensiero perché quello che incasina la
vita per farvi capire meglio questa cosa
questo ci dovrebbe essere eccola qua un
semaforo dove dobbiamo diventare più
consapevoli dei nostri pensieri
ok quindi cosa succede che se ma farò
tre luci cioè la luce rossa la luce già
la luce verde quando ste luce rossa
quando siete molto agitati quindi vuol
dire che avete tanti pensieri nella
testa e questi pensieri porta
un'agitazione in quel caso lì luce rosa
io devo riuscire a fermarmi un attimo e
come fermo il pensiero di solito porta
l'attenzione del presente
se siete in giro nella natura potete
concentrarvi su un albero l'attenzione
la sulla sulla corteccia o sull'erba o
su un profumo che sentite oppure potete
anche semplicemente portare l'attenzione
sul vostro respiro e tenere lì
l'attenzione fino che a un certo punto e
monte rete che il pensiero si calma
automaticamente quindi luce rossa mi
raccomando fermate la vostra mente ve ne
accorgete perché
l'agitazione la sentite che sale luce
gialla quando luce gialla rallentate
perché state bene sì però sentite che li
sta salendo un po di agitazione
quindi vuol dire che c'è un pensiero là
dentro da qualche parte che che potrebbe
diventare pesante opprimente allora devo
rallentare e riportare ancora una volta
l'attenzione nel presente
luce verde è perfetto andati via dritti
perché vuol dire che state utilizzando
venere la vostra mente quindi il
pensiero va il pensiero viene come
dovrebbe essere normalmente l'ultima
cosa per chiudere la vita pratica nel
sempre insegnato molte più cose rispetto
a quelle che ho visto e ho letto sui
libri
io sono appassionato di trekking qualche
anno fa ero sempre a macugnaga scalavo
una montagna di 3000 metri non è
altissima ma ad un certo punto sono
partito la giornata era bellissima se
vedevano sapere il bel cielo limpido
salendo però un certo punto ero circa
2500 metri è arrivata questa nuvolone
questa questo banco di nuvole nebbia in
montagna capita spesso
ecco a quel punto lì cosa potevo fare
potevo preoccuparmi potevo prendermela
continuare andare avanti oppure potevo
fermarmi e quello che ho fatto mi sono
fermato ho tolto i miei scarponcini
appoggiato mio zainetto mi sono mangiato
la mia barretta nella frutta secca
ho aspettato quelle nuvole sono come i
pensieri in quel momento lì voi dovreste
fermarvi non andate avanti per forza
fermatevi lasciate che la mente si calmi
e così è successo a un certo punto le
nuvole si sono aperte a bellissimo
vedevo la cima
mi sono ri massimi e scarponcini il mio
zainetto e sono ripartito a quel punto
lì sono andato dritto dritto dritto fino
ad arrivare alla cima
io vi ringrazio
[Applauso]